in less than two weeks the federal
eviction moratorium will come to an end
the cdc says there will not be another
extension locally
a number of organizations are gearing up
to help those who may be without a home
for the first time in their life
kate houston live in the newsroom with
more on their plan of action
kate yes denise one shelter said they're
expecting a tsunami of people once the
eviction moratorium expires on july 31st
this will add even more strain on local
shelters which are already trying to
assist
thousands of homeless individuals we've
had
lots of individuals who have come in and
have come to us and said like i've never
had
to deal with this before i don't even
know where to start i haven't had to ask
for help
catholic charities of southern nevada is
one of many organizations gearing up for
evictions
if we get again an influx of people we
are ready
and if you know it comes in in small
droves then we're ready for that as well
director of social services nicole
anderson says they're building up their
resources adding more case managers in
the past
month i think it's going to be quite a
bit of people that will need the
assistance
juan salinas with the salvation army
says they're adding more beds in their
shelter and hiring more housing
specialists
we actually added about eight more case
managers
that are able to deal with the different
in the different areas especially with
the moratorium that's going to be very
very helpful
salinas says this is especially
important since the evictions will be an
ongoing process
it's not going to end right away it's
going to get a trickle effect where one
thing leads to another to another
and so we want to be available to meet
those needs
there is a large network of social
services in southern nevada
now all relying on each other to help as
many people as possible come august
first
if we're unable to help them for
whatever reason or salvation army or
whoever is unable to help them
they'll typically reach out and say hey
we have this this family or this
you know person in need what can you
guys do and
everybody kind of jumps in the clark
county
cares housing assistance program or chap
recently received more funding
and is accepting more applications this
can be used for rent and utilities
assistance
the 106 million dollars is expected to
help an additional 40 thousand
households brian